thank you
[Music]
in Florida you guys know about the um
the new law to Santa sign that states
Chinese citizens can't buy property
there I like that dude
I like that
no that's fine it was funny though so
like a lot of a lot of Asian Americans
are like fighting against it and they're
like oh they're so [__] racist I
can't believe and I'm all like they're
protecting us you [__] morons because
your house is a million dollars
these people come they're coming into
Asian neighborhoods they're pricing us
out of our own neighborhoods yeah dude
and they're [__] foreign Nationals
that's not planning to stay here yeah
[__] idiots they don't pay the same
cost we pay that's the yeah originally
it's all next shark comment [__] dude
I wanted to live in Pasadena Arcadia but
I had to move to butt [__] nowhere
Glendora because you try to get us every
you try to get all of us forget everyone
to move wherever I go I love everybody
anyways it would have been a huge
mistake that's true
so I have to move to Glendora because I
was trying to buy a house in Arcadia and
uh we did the regular route which is
look at like all the homes we looked at
30 40 homes
um I couldn't find ones that either like
fit certain requirements or pricing
whatever and then so what we did is you
do this other theme where um you can
find like people's deeds and you can
just message them and then that way like
people like oh would you like to start a
house and some people get in the mail oh
yeah I'll sell my house for this much or
whatever so my realtor found exact homes
a lot size bathrooms uh bedrooms that
I'm looking for and then specifically
sent it to those homes a lot of them
come back and it's like Ling long
Trading Company Ching Chong [__] LLC
Bing Bong whatever and a lot of them are
just a pattern I can tell you that's
Chinese
and a lot of them are just like money
being parked here in Arcadia exactly and
we'll go look at the house right yeah
and they hire someone pull the trash in
and out [__] mow the lawn do
everything and then you look and the
house is empty empty yeah so many houses
and that's the reason why a lot of these
[__] homes are [__] going up crazy
especially in the Asian neighborhoods
because of those [__] that's
why I don't [__] understand these
next shark commenters that are like no
we need to [__] we need to keep this
[__] stop being racist it's like they're
not talking about Asian Americans
they're talking about Chinese foreign
Nationals that [__] buy houses as
investment properties
they price us out out of our own
neighborhoods and our own communities
and then just like Bart's example we
have all these ghost homes yeah because
now they're communities yeah Chinese
investment companies with 10 homes and
now we don't have an Asian Community but
those people leaving comments they're
not buying houses no they're the ones
that are selling houses and they want
the Chinese to come because they're just
like they're just like that's exactly
right I want to [__] sell my house
for 2 two million dollar Realtors there
is such a movement of that though and
it's so funny too because people will
actively root against their own
self-interests if you can make them mad
enough about something it's so stupid
man the strange thing too is I feel like
a lot of those people with that opinion
haven't left the country enough to know
that Americans can't buy land in other
countries too yeah there's a lot of
countries where if you're are you a
citizen you can't do that dude we can't
buy land in China okay like singaporeans
I don't know dude you can't go to
Southeast Asia and buy land if you're
not a resident and guess what if their
government wants to seize land for
whatever reason necessary if we buy land
for like you know how many times that
happens to Americans where it just gets
snatched up like that do you think we
get the same type of rights that they do
when they buy land property and like no
it's protected that's why foreign
Nationals love buying land in America in
Western countries is because we uphold
that intellectual property we uphold you
know property and individual rights so
I'm all like why do they get to benefit
and also overrun our communities that's
why I'm like good for Florida man you're
probably if you have Asian communities
in Florida too you're probably
protecting them first and foremost and
nobody talks about this either Graham
Stefan needs to block China from being
able to watch his videos because
obviously they're watching this videos
and they're going I gotta buy real
estate this is [__] great and that's
where it's all coming from if grand7
needs to knock the [__] off dude he's
giving too many people in in China good
ideas blowing up the spot his content's
too good also the uh this content is
really good and also one of the worst
case scenarios that uh Florida is
looking out for it's not primarily the
residential
it's Farmland yes because Chinese
companies are buying a lot of farmland
and people are not regular people like
like you know those Bill Gates for some
reason Bill Gates is buying shitloads of
Farmland she's yeah should we buy a farm
guys that's a scary thing also they're
buying a lot of land close to the
military bases
which is weird kind of weird the Chinese
spies that just got caught pretending to
be tourists and then they went to an
Alaskan military base and started taking
pictures all over the [__] place oh
my God
I took her all the time
oh so so here's to play the other side a
little bit
um and maybe there's a there's a
rationale here so you're approach Island
right now
he's putting his approach trying to
happen let me let me channel that
um so some people that like the people
that we're talking about that are
against this they see it as it's
stifling to Asian Americans who are like
have a green card but they're not
citizens so like uh the generation that
moved over here and tried to start
stores and buy like uh property in order
to make businesses now you can't do that
so I have nothing anyway I thought they
they allow permanent residents to buy
property it was it was just not it was
not foreign Nationals that are allowed I
think uh that might have been the Texas
one because the Texas one had pushback
the Texas one was like this and then a
bunch of people complained and they
changed it and made it like more like
softer because green card holders they
allowed but if you're not a permanent
resident it might be then you can't buy
property here so I'm for if they went
through the pipeline like how all of our
parents and everyone like else does so
like if you go through like I I want to
be a patriot of this country I become
you get a working Visa then you get your
green card your permanent residence and
then you become a citizen and you buy a
home I'm not against that because people
come here for a better life I think
that's dope and if you follow the rules
the way everyone else did that's cool
but when you're like I'm gonna buy a
home there and I'm never gonna live
there I'm still gonna live over here
then you're [__] pricing up the house
over here and you're affecting all the
local communities and you're not even
using the home and you're not paying the
energy costs like the same way with the
same resources in that area right having
a job in that area it just changes the
landscape completely yeah and people
feel priced out they don't feel
represented they do need people to run
for office who can represent their
ideals right like I think that's a good
point at me what happened to you
I'm sure the one to save us all wrong
I think you have it I think you should
run for something because I think so too
I think you should I think you should
you already have all these awards for
your your your [__] I'll find you
some factors don't you worry yeah we'll
look at kids don't even worry about it
we'll set you up I know orange yeah
orange this sounds good something like
that please run for Pasadena maybe or
cities that rhyme with Irvine orange
anything anything but South Gate you
could be like this could be like that
Back to the Future moment for you right
now you're like mayor
I like the sound of that yeah
Goldie Wilson
yeah so do you think that this is an
active xenophobia at all well okay
um
so on the flip side the argument for
people that are against this is saying
that when you make it like one nation
like a Chinese you're not We're not
gonna allow Chinese right then they're
saying that for the for the dumbasses
out there that don't know the difference
between Asian American and Chinese we're
gonna be discriminated a government
China right like a different thing so
they're like so then so those people are
saying that but I'm all like
well
ultimately let's look at the bigger
picture here is that
um not everyone's dumb and racist yeah
you might have one dumb land owner that
don't know the difference between a
Japanese American and a [__] Chinese
National which is to me extremely
[__] rare like that that does exist
but like that's rare most people are
sensible most people are normal right
and so you're not gonna have issues
buying commercial property or
residential property
um and and if and if they do then
they're just flat out racist and you can
combat that independently you can deal
with that yeah and have a lawsuit
against that discriminatory practice
sure yeah but I think bigger picture
like we should try our best to keep
foreign Nationals to investing into
America and for many reasons because
um another another reason for this is
because they use real estate for money
laundering not just China but a lot of
other countries yeah when they embezzle
money they siphon it out of their
country and to Safe Haven it they put it
into Western countries that's why you
have these 20 million dollar homes
that's their Bank the rich to play this
game oligarchs really love this they
throw this money in there and then once
they have a 20 million dollar house they
can get a mortgage or whatever they want
on it like a HELOC or whatever they they
use they use that up as collateral and
then now they can start using money
tax-free in America or whatever right so
it's like
because you have that like this is
happening in Hawaii where you have these
like beachfront properties that are 20
million dollars so it's an island so
obviously the comps in that area it's
gonna Skyrocket so you have a shack next
to a 20 20 million dollar property The
Shack should be no more than a hundred
thousand dollars but because of that
proximity yeah now uh cop meaning
comparison oh because it's so close to
that property now that hundred thousand
dollar house is like a million you can't
buy it anymore and now it's only for a
certain class and then yeah the 90 price
the locals out yeah it could even be
Statewide you know like you have a bunch
of like Californians buying homes in
Hawaii you can price out the locals from
their own homesters is there like and
I'm sorry to do this too because I hate
when people do this to me when I'm
hosting but can you can you
um as a Chinese citizen can I only buy
one property in America or is it like I
can buy as many as I want because if if
you're an American you can buy property
in China but you can only buy my
understanding you can only buy one piece
of property because I just Googled it in
all of China That's the Law apparently I
just Googled it wow so it's a fresh [__]
well right now I don't know but when I
was looking especially in the Asian
neighborhoods there were so many just
empty homes owned by these Chinese
corporations
and that's definitely Chinese I can tell
you
check this out though foreigners are
allowed to purchase property in China
the essential requirement is that you
have studied or worked in China for at
least one year on a residence permit
foreigners are allowed to only own one
residential property key to this is that
it's for dwelling purposes
you spend a year there right now they
got people that just they just empty
yeah they haven't even visited they just
buy it like sight unseen ching chong LLC
is just buying up all the stuff that's
ching chong Trading Company both are
Chinese
get it right dude
uh it says there's no restrictions on
foreigners buying property in the US
because they got all the money baby our
politicians are owned
they're not looking out for you that's
when they said America's for sale it's
for [__] sale bro so yeah please uh
try to look beyond what might appear
racist and just maybe see the logistics
China sticks up for their citizens
better than our people do they do
actually we're kind of dropping the ball
on ourselves because I I slept for money
dude Yep this is a good case for in
general having foreign
government-backed investment companies
with unlimited funds that can price you
out we should try our best to keep that
out so we can actually have communities
you know where we can all stay for
generations and like that happened here
in Monterey Park that's happening and
why that's happening in many places all
over the U.S where people are getting
there's it's hard to be a middle class
member of society it's squeezed and how
many people get pushed right so we
always talk about homeless encampments
and like all this stuff but how many
people got pushed there right yep how
many people got squeezed out of
prosperity by [__] like this by the
corruption right so that's the
outrageous part I mean somebody was
doing something about it and even if you
sell your house right let's say you
benefited from this because you sold
your house for a million dollars guess
what the next house you buy it's the
same damn price yeah so what are you
doing anyway you're just going and
moving for the same price it's or or for
a little discount and most of these
companies this is their game plan and
they'll pay cash they'll pay over asking
so it's hard to compete for a young
family out there that's trying to buy a
starter home like Nick you know and
priced out over here right Vegas
gotta go to Vegas so far it says that
every year
um every year for the past decade the
top the top foreign buyer of American
land is China damn so it makes a lot of
sense to block them and to me and
generally that if you think about it
right the trade deficit like think about
it right we can't our companies and we
can't buy and invest into them the way
that they can into us I don't want to
even buy in that polluted ass place you
can't even see the sky